when I teach I tell the students on the  first day I'm not your teacher your  teacher is gonna be Plato and Aristotle  and Aquinas and Khan wouldn't that be  presumptuous for me I said I'm gonna  teach you philosophy and not appeal to  the best that's been thought and said  for me I didn't realize how much I would  learn as a student in courses outside of  my discipline it's really important for  me to make sure students in other parts  of campus understand how important the  sciences are in the liberal arts the  liberal arts really unmet to liberate us  from the things of this rule so we're  not so caught up in this specific moment  or this generation but it allows us to  see across time in Spanish for example  we study the great playwrights  of the 17th century and they are  exploring what does it mean to live a  life dedicated to truth